My husband and I are composted our poo at our homestead after two years our first batch looks
Like a really good product
But we are wondered if it's safe to use in the garden since my husband does not eat organic to the microorganisms in the compost
Take care of any toxins chemicals from non-organic processed foods
Well first of all, even if you are taking compost from your let's say you have livestock and let's say you are feeding organic chicken feed to your chickens
Well your chickens if you are free-ranging your chickens in the summer they're eating your grass which is not sprayed with any toxins
And if that's going to be a much more organic product right but let's say you're getting compost for your garden from the neighbor who has cows and they're not feeding their cows organic
And they're spraying their fields for weeds which I'm not sure that anybody that's pasturing cattle is spraying their fields for weeds
But let's pretend well they're feeding grain so let's say it's not grass fed and they're not grass fed and they're feeding GMO corn which for sure cattle would be eating
And you're taking that cattle manure composted and putting it on your garden are you getting round up in that garden
Yeah the danger is real yes you are so you just have to be aware of that the danger is real
Now would I personally in my garden use human feces, human excrement composted in my garden no I wouldn't
Could you put it elsewhere in your yard, elsewhere you know to fertilize a field that maybe your cattle are on or something like that
I don't see any harm in that I don't know if any harm in that is there are there microorganisms in the compost that are taking care of toxins
chemicals from the unorganic processed foods
No it depends on the toxin itself
microorganisms will take care of certain things
And not other things for instance use an example of very widely used
broadleaf herbicide
abbreviated 2-4-D
So why does the golf course not have any weeds on it because they're sprayed 2-4-D like crazy
Why does the park that you take your kids go and play on not have any
dandelions because they're sprayed 2-4-D maybe that is off it is golf course but they're sprayed 2-4-D on it
2-4-D is the most commonly used herbicide in home herbicide remedies
like if you have it can be used as a granular it can be used as a spray it's in certain things
you'd have to read the ingredients on it but if you're putting some you're going to lose and you're buying a
and a fertilizer slash herbicide for your yard and and putting that on pretty much
guaranteed it's got 2-4-D now the pros and cons of 2-4-D pros are it's going to kill it's going to kill
weeds it's going to kill dandelions you're not going to be dandelions in your yard
um the the negative is it's highly toxic, highly toxic maybe even more toxic than roundup glyphosate
but one positive of 2-4-D is that the soil has microorganisms in it that break it down
it's got a half life of I think like 10 days or something like that in the soil by soil microorganisms
now if you took that that herbicide and you just ate it that's how you just consume 2-4-D
you don't have those microorganisms to break it down but they are in the soil so you could have
toxicity in a matter of fact that talks detect tests tests for 2-4-D so you could have elevated
the levels of 2-4-D because you ate a plant that was contaminated with 2-4-D immediately it
was sprayed more recently than you know a month and a half ago because it would be pretty much
all gone within maybe a couple months but let's say you ate that plant that was sprayed with 2-4-D
now it's in your body now it's got a half life of like a million years it's not going to be broken
down by your microorganisms you have to detoxify it so are there microorganisms in that compost that
are going to break down some toxins like 2-4-D I don't know glyphosate on the other hand doesn't have
microorganisms to break it down and that's the negative of glyphosate it is also toxic and can
be cancer-causing but it's more prevalent in certain crops and it is more so it's more ubiquitous
and it's more toxic as far as you're just never going to break that down in your body either it
doesn't break down in the soil so that's why to be listed as organic you have to let your soil sit
for five years and get retested because it takes that lung for to break down glyphosate so when I
use compost from human excrement on my garden personally I wouldn't I don't know that it's been
researched enough to know that I just I wouldn't do that